I don't know Pokemon well enough to do a
joke so first trailer for detective
Pikachu came out and let me tell you I
really did not plan to make a video
about that like very blatantly I saw
that it was out of like some people are
asking I'm not gonna do a video on this
because I Pokemon passed me by to be
completely honest I I think part of it
is I'm a little bit too old for when the
craze really started hitting so like I I
played I don't know somewhere between
four and six hours worth of the original
game and when I say the original game I
mean the Gameboy game okay not original
original because original was pokémon
red and blue
I got pokemon yellow which was the one
that got you Pikachu off the bat but you
know that was still just a version of
the original game so I played that for a
little bit I didn't hate it but it
didn't grab me starting to keep playing
I didn't watch the cartoon I'd like I
got I got it through osmosis I know what
it's about but I didn't watch the
cartoon I haven't played the subsequent
games I haven't done any of the card
games I didn't do Pokemon go like I just
Pokemon it's just not my bag I get that
a lot of people love him but it's just
it's just something I never got into
pass me by it happens so I really felt
like I have nothing to say about this
thing and then I looked at the trailer
one that is bizarrely engaging what the
hell like it's really weird like the
whole thing the whole vibe of it is
bizarre in a way that I'm just intrigued
by which I did not expect like at all
but I I honestly don't really know what
to make of this thing
except I'm kind of fascinated by it I
think it's something about taking a
property like Pokemon that has been
around forever and has like it has a
very standard storytelling template you
know there have been Pokemon movies and
comics and you know who knows how many
cartoons and the games all have the same
narrative about you know becoming a
pokemon trainer and collecting Pokemon
in battle they have a program I like
that's what the sort of these games are
there's something about a story being
set in a world that basically always
tells the exact same narrative and not
telling that story but telling a
different story but still very much in
that world no man it's it's just kind of
funny
it's then the vibe of it is is really
weird
it's like okay imagine like if prior to
Blade Runner being made replicants had
been a massive franchise and there was
like a replicants TV show and you know a
comic book line and all these novels
about the history of development of
these robots and and all this stuff and
then this and then the movie version
comes out and it's about a detective and
the replicants are there but it's not
really about them it's just in the world
that we've always been chosen that's
what it feels like and I know it feels
really weird to compare detective
Pikachu to Blade Runner but and that's
honestly that was the that was the
default my brain kept going to maybe it
has to do with just that scene of a
Pikachu and whoever the guy is justice
Smith is the the actor I didn't catch
the character name but and you know sort
of in this this neon ish series of
stalls maybe that's what set off the
Blade Runner comparison in my head I
don't know but yeah it was bizarrely
intriguing and I kinda liked that I mean
who knows if they'll be one in the movie
but I like that as far as a trailer goes
there's no explanation for why we added
this character can understand
and what this Pikachu is saying instead
of just hearing beep and all that stuff
so like because we don't need to know
why I mean it's gonna be that way for
the story to function them for the movie
to work why who cares
let's I mean that's just how it is let's
move on and know what kind of like that
and you know and there's there's
obviously gonna be some kind of mystery
and you know he's got his father I guess
his father's missing but like the whole
vibe is not what I would have expected
from honestly a Pokemon anything much
less something with Pikachu's name in
the title it was a little like visually
a little darker or a little more dour a
little it wasn't the bright vibrant
kaleidoscope of color you would expect
it felt and then the Pokemon that we saw
felt more integrated into the world than
I would have expected like this this
whole project is bizarre and even more
bizarrely now that I've seen some of it
I'm like holy crap is that actually
working because I think it's working
what is going on it's got its it's gonna
be a weird world if I end up going to
because I'm not making the call right
now then we're gonna go see it in the
theater but it will be a very strange
world if I do see this thing in the
theatre and end up really enjoying it
that will be so weird and that'll come
out of nowhere on so many levels but I
had said the vibe off this thing was so
strange and in an engaging way not
enough boy that was a weird go do
something else like stuck in my head
weird whoa detective Pikachu first
trailer what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are dropping me
down to comment let's talk about it
please we got let's talk this one out a
whole bunch of stuff you can do as well
cuz there's buttons and there's links
including a link to the patreon if you
feel like supporting me in them
if you don't thought don't sweat it
because there's nothing links to check
out as well but if you don't want to do
any of that don't even worry about it
cuz at the end of the day folks you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]